[Musique]
le sentiment que les gens ressortent
lorsqu'ils entendent de la Soka pour la
première fois c'est de
[Musique]
l'euphorie cette musique a tendance à
rendre tout plus
heureux je veux juste donner de bonnes
vibrations à chaque personne que je
rencontre avec la musique
[Musique]
socca de S off Calypso et quand on prend
évidemment sa de sa de cas de Calypso ça
a créé la
[Musique]
S le vendredi soir à Savana il faut
suivre appelle des percussions
métalliques pour savoir où se trouve le
point de
ralliment la plus grande place de la
capitale est occupé par plus de 50
groupes de
[Musique]
stypan chacun est venu de son côté pour
répéter son prochain spectacle la
joyeuse cacophonie a attiré sur place
plus de 10000
personnes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
face à des musiciens
envoûtés le public se déchaîne qu'il
soit amis ou de parfaits inconnus il
suffit d'un pas de danse complice pour
se laisser
[Musique]
entraîner c'est l'effet de
laasoka
comment ça se danse on se l' juste
porter par la musique c'est
tout tu écoutes la musique et tu bouges
tes hanches tu ressens la musique tu
fais les mouvements qui te passent par
la tête c'est l'expression de ton corps
de ce que tu ressens à l'intérieur tu le
laisses sortir et ça donne une
[Musique]
danse
et c'est ainsi depuis 50 ans Savana
s'endort et se réveille au rythme de
laasoka ce matinl ce sont les sportifs
qui prennent le relais dans un registre
plus
moderne
question son de basse avec musique
enregistrée et entre les mains de
l'ambianceur un micro à remplacé les
traditionnelles
[Musique]
baguettes quand j'entends de laaska je
me sens capable d'aider les autres à se
sentir bien parce qu'avec notre on
diffuse beaucoup de bonne énergie et
quand il y a du monde comme aujourd'hui
je veux m'assurer que tout le monde
s'amuse parce que dans le monde dans
lequel nous vivons il y a assez de
malheur il faut qu'on a des gens qui
transmettent cette bonne
énergie quand j'entends de laasa moi
aussi j'ai envie d'entraîner tout le
monde avec
moi les vibrations positives
seraient-ell la recette miracle de ce
succès en 50 ans d'existence laoka s'est
imé dans l'ADN des trinidadien comme un
maillon de l'identité
culturelle une histoire d'amour que ce
Français a contribué à faire rayonner
aux quatre coins du monde il y a
beaucoup de de souvenirs dans cette
maison et je peux vous les présenter si
vous voulez bah il y a déjà pas mal de
de de titres qu'on a eu à différents
niveaux sur trinida des tobego
principalement comme étant des des
entrepreneurs qui ont poussé la la
Jean-Michel Gibert est arrivé à
Trinidade par amour il y a tout juste 30
ans passionné de musique il lance sa
société de production et découvre des
talents uniques totalement inconnus du
grand public il décide alors de se
battre à leur côté pour qu'il gagne en
visibilité petit à petit le label
parvient à faire reconnaître le talent
de plusieurs artistes le suwiite musique
disque d'or avec
chougardadi
[Musique]
Marvin ses chanteurs rayonnent dans la
Caraïb et sur les scènes américaines
mais sa plus grande fierté reste la
collaboration avec calypso Rose figure
emblématique du genre musical dont elle
prend le nom dès ses début dans les
années
[Musique]
50 première femme à remporté le monarque
du calypso en 78 elle inonde le marché
de ses productions 30 albums soit plus
de 800 chansons en quelques dizaines
d'années pourtant l'artiste a dû
attendre 2016 pour la reconnaissance
internationale et puis bien s de platine
de calypso Rose donc et ça effectivement
c'est des oui voilà c'est des vrais
c'est des vrais beau souvenirs
récompense tardive pour celle qui a
révolutionné le calypso jusqu'à inspirer
la naissance de laasa avec ce titre
action sorti en
[Musique]
elle revendique un petit peu aussi la
naissance de la Soka mais étant une
femme elle n'a pas été
[Musique]
reconnue la paternité du genre est
attribué 3 ans plus tard au chanteur
Garfield Blackman plus connu sous le nom
de
R et voici le titre
indrani ah et c'est ce qui est considéré
comme la première so
donc le mélange des rythmes indiens avec
les rythmes africains il a beaucoup
sexualisé
indrani la femme indienne et ça a été à
l'époque elle a été interdite cette
chanson même par le
gouvernement un esprit rebelle
provocateur cultivé par le clan Blackman
de génération en
génération et voici la relève naayla
Blackman la petite fille de
rash c'est elle qui reprend le
flambau érigé au rang de princesse de
laasoka elle met le public trinidadien à
ses pieds 500000 followers sur Instagram
une trentaine de titres à son actif en
moins de 5 ans de carrière
50 ans après son grand-père c'est à son
tour de dévergonder les scènes mus
la provocation dans les mots mais aussi
il est tenu le
déanch NA Blackman incarne plus qu'un
genre musical elle est pour son public
l'icône de toute une
génération je suis tellement fier de
tout ce qu'elle a accomp je pense que
nous devons soutenir laaska parce
qu'elle peut aller beaucoup plus loin
que là où elle est aujourd'hui na
Blackman est un exemple toute la Caraïbe
je suis vraiment très
fiable le fruit d'un travail acharné à
25 ans la jeune artiste s'impose un
rythme
militaire je P tellement que parfois
j'en perds la
voix je fais trop de concert elle se
rend au studio pratiquement tous les
jours de la semaine pour créer composer
répéter avec les embouteillages le
trajet peut prendre jusqu'à 1 heure
alors pour ne pas perdre de temps elle
s'échauffe en
voiture cette chanson s'appelle laoren
elle est d'un ancien chanteur de Calypso
qui s'appelait lexpliner il est décédé
le mois
dernier je l'ai chanté pour lui rendre
hommage lors de mon concert du coup j'ai
la mélodie en tête
[Musique]
je l'ai déjà allumé non l'autre celuil
non toi tu
l'allumes le producteur est en place la
séance de travail peut commencer
aujourd'hui l'accent est mis sur sa
toute dernière
composition une node Calypso sur des
rythmes de
[Musique]
Soka
c'est comme si je portais un flambeau
très très
lumineux beaucoup de gens ne connaissent
pas la Soka donc on leur apporte quelque
chose de nouveau de joyeux de
divertissant j'aimerais faire des scènes
partout dans le
monde j'ai déjà été dans beaucoup
d'endroits mais j'aimerais faire des
festivals en Europe
aux
États-Unis j'ai déjà eu la chance de
participer au Coachella mais j'adoris
faire la scène
principale j'aimerais faire des scènes
en Afrique Afrique du Sud Nigéria
Sénégal Ghana je me sens capable
d'apporter cette musique dans des lieux
où elle n'a pas encore été entendue
repousser les limites de la la même idée
fixe que ses
prédécesseur avec tout de même une
stratégie novatrice introduire d'autres
langues que l'anglais dans ses
créations comme le
[Musique]
français que vous C PLA c'est ça la vi
ce soir t pensé oui c'est ça la
viarrê FA la dans mon
PS NAA Blackman espère inscrire son nom
au pantéon de la Soka au côté de son
grand-père mais aussi de Machel Montan
[Musique]
le trinidadien rgnant maître sur le
monde de la Soka depuis plus de 30 ans
élu en 2007 personnalité de scène la
plus remarquable international reg World
musicoub par Drake en feuring avec il
les étoiles et tr un boulevard pour ses
homologues comme band
ce titre hello est son plus gros
succès près de 40 millions de vues
comptabilisés sur Youtube la chanson a
fait le tour du monde par les
plateformes d'écout mais ai les
[Musique]
show
on a quelques chansons qui ont été
décisiv pour nous en fait clair
par leot
lume est
univers
comprend
et la musique on peut dire qu'elle est
hybride ça ressemble à de la Soka mais
aussi à de
l'robite jouer sur plusieurs tableaux
une stratégie
assumé au premier regard on aurait juré
un groupe de rock avec ingénieur du son
bassiste guitariste clavier
batteur
cette vitrine est pensée de toutes
pièces pour toucher le plus large public
possible mais une fois l'audience
accroché c'est bien la Soka qui
[Musique]
s'impose c'est une très bonne question
on a pas mal expérimenté c'est
[Musique]
vrai à no début on avait un catalogue
pop et un autre pour laaska c'était du
monde à
part et je pense qu'on a toujours rêvé
de trouver la bonne formule pour que
tous ces mondes arrivent à se mélanger
ce n'est pas du dans
sol ce n pas du
regeton
c'est une sorte de rythme africain très
chaloupé cette musique a tendance à
rendre tout plus
heureux qui la r
spécial donc on l'entend pour la
première fois surtout en
live les gens ressentent quelque chose
qu'il n'ont jamais éproué et l'oubl
jamais j'ai l'occasion de voir des
spectateurs venir un concert puis un
autre et puis à la fin se retrouver à
Trinidade pour le carnaval et tout ça ça
part d'un concert qui a
changé la scène est donc son meilleur à
tout alororest travaille chacune de ses
apparitions jusque dans ses interactions
avec le
public tout est
millimétré
toute la production du chanteur se
trouve aux États-Unis mais il a choisi
de se domicilier à Trinidad car il
entend participer à la
professionnalisation du genre
[Musique]
musicaluton trouve y d'être plus
constructif créer des opportunités pour
que les anciens puissent parler au
nouveau pour les
encourager pour leur donner un tremplin
plutôt que de les voir comme des
[Musique]
concurrents il faut qu'on fasse des
festivals partout sur terre pas dans la
concurrence mais au contraire dans la
bienveillance n CR
l'anniversaire des 50 ans de la Soka est
l'occasion d'impulser cette dynamique
toute l'année 2023 les événements se
sont multipliés sur le territoire
offrant au milliers de chanteurs
amateurs des espace d'expression digne
des plus
grands ici au moins 3000 personnes sont
rassemblés pour voir défiler une dizaine
d'artistes plus ou moins
connus
et c'est à présent au tour de de mon en
le public est tout de suite accroché ce
titre écrit il y a 2 ans et sa plus
grande
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
réussite
un rêve éveillé pour ce coiffeur de
profession originaire d'un petit
quartier de San
Fernando en quête du grand succès dev
continue décumer les scènes dans
l'espoir de percer une nouvelle fois
avec d'autres
créations
je suis venu présenter de nouveaux
morceaux mais aussi jouer d'anciens
morceaux amener ma bonne énergie et
m'assurer que tout le monde
s'amuse j'essaie de faire découvrir la
Soka au monde entier tout comme les
autres artistes on essaie de faire une
percée pour que la Soka devienne un
genre musical connu mondialement et
pourquoi pas un jour gagner un GR voir
de ou tr on trace la route pour les plus
jeunes de la même façon que les anciens
l'ont fait pour nous les grandes scènes
à l'américaine il s'y croirait presque
en coulisse l'artiste est tout de suite
hé par une horde de médias télévisé ou
connectés sur les réseaux
sociaux on va très peu les questionner
sur eux-mêmes et sur leur
musé mais plus sur comment ils se
sentent de remonter sur scène dans ce
lieu magique unique et rempli d'
une partie de notre public s moque et
perdument mais la majorité respecte les
artistes et s'intéresse à ce qu'il
ressentent et c'est pourquoi on tient à
les interview à leur sortie de
[Musique]
scène l'animatrice er souhaite elle-même
devenir un jour chanteuse de Soka entre
deux émissions elle loue régulièrement
un studio avec ses amis pour enregistrer
ses créations afin de les envoyer aux
producteurs le même rêve partagé par des
milliers de jeunes Trinidadiens autant
de nouvelles chansons de sooka qui
sortent chaque année pour se challenger
sur les scènes locales ou les
[Musique]
radios
et le phénomène promet de ne faire que
prendre de l'ampleur car la future
concurrence est déjà en train de
[Musique]
s'échauffer
[Applaudissements]
l
và
S